[Music]
the only rule for eating a taco is that
once you have it ready
you don't put it down you just finish it
i grew up in a family where food was the
glue of
everything cooking eating and sitting
around the table
brings people together in a way that few
things do
i never set out to become a chef i
opened a restaurant
and it was a farm to table restaurant in
mexico city when that was not
the general trend it was so successful
that i turned it into my career
this class is for everybody and anybody
who's interested in food
it's important to know about other
cultures through food
i'm going to teach you how to make a few
delicious salsas
oh my goodness it's so good
and i'm going to teach you how to make
tortillas
from age seven i became the resident
tortilla maker
in my house it was the first thing i
learned to cook it's actually a fairly
easy
process there's nothing like a
fresh-made tortilla there really isn't
we're gonna make tacos al pastor the
dish of mexico city
and it's a street food it's a rub with
chilis fresh vegetables
and spices the aroma is really
enticing
[Music]
but it's so good it's very typical of
mexican culture to start the day off
with eggs we're going to make huevos
rancheros divorciado using a green sauce
and a red sauce
i'm gonna put a little bit of water
they're gonna roast for half an hour
and meanwhile we do nothing
[Laughter]
i really urge you to pay attention to
every
bit of what you put into the dish just
in a way in which you translate your
enjoyment
[Music]
and i know it's not always easy but the
more one can connect with people over
a shared love of a delightful dish the
better off
your result will be i am gabriela camara
and this
is my master class
[Music]
you